too long too short to English here's why
some fans are complaining that Avatar 2
is only around to set up sequels
the choice to cast Sigourney Weaver as a
Teenage Nabi character in avatar The Way
of water left Avatar fans divided to say
the least some fans had no problem
accepting Weber in the role of a
teenager as one person tweeted I
Honestly Love James Cameron for casting
an older woman in the role we have
accepted way too much ageism in
Hollywood yet for many others the motion
capture was only convincing until Kiri
opened her mouth despite Weaver's best
efforts it's apparently difficult to
pass the voice of a 73 year old woman as
a 14 year old girl however a lot of fans
just weren't fooled as one fan said I'm
sorry Sigourney Weaver is a great
actress but she does not work as the
voice of the kid
oh
who's got my damn cigarette
the fact that there's a narrative reason
behind this casting Choice only slightly
alleviates the bizarreness of seeing a
teenage Sigourney Weaver canonically
Kiri has been confirmed to be the
daughter of Grace's Avatar so it makes
sense that she would sound just like her
mother and perhaps she's more than just
Grace's daughter as one Reddit user
speculated could Kiri be some kind of
Reincarnation of Grace facilitated by
AWA if so then the casting Choice makes
a lot of sense
Jim Cameron says I'm very immature and
this should be right up my alley Jake
and natiri were undoubtedly the
protagonist of Avatar but with the
second movie their role is a little more
complicated Jake is certainly Central to
the plot he's the one with the Target on
his back and his decisions kick the
story into motion but for a main
character he doesn't get a lot of screen
time nor does natiri den of geek
observed for much of the middle section
in the movie Jake and the teary
themselves are strangely passive the
role in the second act is mostly just to
react to what their children have been
doing Jake and iteri both take the back
seat for most of the film letting their
kids do the driving the Sully children
especially lowak Kiri and spider are
main characters in their own right and
they get plenty of wonderful character
development however many fans still miss
Jake and natiri some were especially
disappointed by natiri's limited screen
time and felt that natiri barely left a
dent in the sequel one person tweeted
she screams and fights but if her
dialogue reached 50 words I'd be
surprised still fans are at least glad
that natiri absolutely stole the scene
when she finally got a chance to shine
in the final battle
Jake and the teary weren't the only
characters who got the short end of the
stick the film has a gigantic cast with
two parents and five children plus
several more humans and met kaina
something was bound to slip through the
cracks on a Reddit Forum about the movie
One user complained that despite all the
buzz about Kate Winslet joining the cast
as Ronald her character wasn't given
much to do and while the story didn't
strictly need more scenes with Parker
Selfridge some fans actually missed his
presence one fan wrote a little bit
disappointed Selfridge was just a cameo
I thought a business suit type was a
nice yin yang Dynamic with the military
in the first movie
you see that yes sir no you didn't you
were looking at the monitor
even characters with a lot of screen
time like low OCT feel underdeveloped as
one fan noted the film could have been
even better if it spent a little longer
in lowatt growing to become friends with
his former bully perhaps the movie's
biggest sin is neglecting to develop
nateam since it's the last movie where
the character will appear as far as one
Reddit user was concerned I felt more
sadness about the depth of the whale on
her cap than about Jake's oldest son
dying
if something seemed a little bit off
while you were watching avatar the way
of water that's probably because you
noticed the movie's frame rate most
movies are shot at 24 frames per second
but the way of water was filmed at 48
frames per second as James Cameron
explained we're using High frame rate to
improve the 3D where we want to
heightened sense of presence such as
underwater or in some of the flying
scenes her shots of just people standing
around talking High frame rate works
against us because it creates a kind of
hyper realism in scenes that are more
mundane more normal viewers have said
that the frame rate made the film look
like a video game or a soap opera
meanwhile The Verge compared it to
watching quote a very expensive video
meant to be played on an array of
televisions in a Best Buy some fans were
comfortable with the 48 frames per
second but felt it was distracting when
the film switched back to 24 frames per
second one Reddit user pointed out that
the film would often toggle back and
forth between different frame rates
within a single scene they wrote that
sounds jarring that is because it was
one thing fans wanted to see more of was
the recombian soldiers recoms for short
supposedly kwara Rich Wayne Fleet and
the other recoms are a close-knit bunch
of soldiers who knew each other before
they were reborn in Navi bodies I know
you're all asking yourselves the same
question why so blue the viewers may
have a hard time buying that because
quarrich's buddies get zero character
development furthermore fans argue that
the recoms don't seem like much of a
threat Jake and natiri managed to take
them out almost single-handedly other
fans shared this sentiment with one
saying I love love loved the idea that
the RDA is using native fauna to slip
past AWA I was looking forward to seeing
them adapt more to their Navi bodies and
figure out the advantages but they just
kind of did what any six foot human
could have done while there's still a
chance that the recoms will get more
development in future movies some fans
may not want to wait that long
many fans watching avatar the way of
water were wondering why there was so
much English spoken as opposed to Navi
school begins Jake is considered one of
the navi and speaks her language so
shouldn't the movie have been entirely
in the Nabi language with English
subtitles the film does offer an
explanation for the switch even if fans
feel it's a contrived one Jake explains
that he has become accustomed to the
native tongue saying that it might as
well be English and that's when the
audio switches to English one Reddit
user wrote I understand why they did it
I just thought it was done without
finesse the subtlety of the linguistic
Switcheroo aside there's one particular
aspect of the dialogue and Avatar the
way of water that has elicited a strong
response from fans and not a good one
for some reason the teenage Navi
characters use slang words like cuz or
sick and the word bro is spoken several
times like all these aliens learned
English from 2000's era comedies wait
what about mine dude what does mine say
it's sweet what about mine dude what
does mine say
According to some Reddit users the slang
is cringe-worthy because it doesn't seem
in character for the navi one fan on
Reddit offered up an explanation
pointing out that the navi probably
aren't literally saying bro rather they
are using the navi equivalent which
Probably sounds less ridiculous and it
is translated for viewers just like
everything else the navi says as one
user said I just took it as when they're
speaking English it's Jake's
interpretation it makes sense Jake may
have many fine qualities but he's never
been a Wordsmith
oh here I am
doing science
mostly redditors wish the filmmakers had
taken the time to develop an equivalent
knobby word with a similar connotation
instead of relying on bro all the time
there's one thing fans and critics
mostly seem to agree on avatar the way
of water is a little too long certainly
the first avatar in Cameron's previous
filmography set a precedent remember the
double VHS set that held Titanic's a
Titanic three hour and 14 minute run
time I don't see what all the fuss is
about
it doesn't look any bigger than the
Mauritania you could be blase about
something's reals but not about Titanic
still many fans think Avatar the way of
water had no business being 3 hours and
12 minutes long one person wrote on
Twitter the ending runs a bit long and
the story doesn't justify it the runtime
has even alienated some moviegoers who
enjoy watching super long epics as one
redditor said mind you I regularly
watched The Lord of the Rings extended
editions I'm no stranger to long movies
but Avatar 2 really drags in response to
criticism about the movie's length James
Cameron told Empire magazine I don't
want anybody whining about length when
they sit and binge watch television for
eight hours
fans you can't please them all all the
time for every viewer who thought the
movie was too long it seems there's
someone else who thought it wasn't long
enough despite the film's lengthy run
time one Reddit user argues that the
movie's pacing often feels too fast
rather than too slow Cameron tries to
rush quickly through the First Act to
get Jake and his family to the Met
kainik Clan as quickly as possible
without giving the characters time to
breathe we barely get to see Jake
mourning what he's leaving behind for
one redditor the movie is actually
strongest when it takes its time they
wrote the downtime is what makes Avatar
so special in my opinion I come to these
movies for action and thrills yes but
also just to be immersed in an alien
world of course some fans think the
movie didn't need to be longer but still
wish that Cameron had cut a few subplots
so that the filmmakers could focus on
the most important storylines another
person took to Reddit to say it's
clearly a project of deep passion and
love and I respect that but I think that
passion also resulted in too many ideas
being crammed into a run time that was
already bursting at the seams in other
words the three-hour running time might
have been better spent on further
development for the main characters
while there is nothing in avatar The Way
of water as obvious as the infinity
stone scenes shoehorned into Avengers
Age of Ultron there are still several
plot threads introduced in this movie
that won't reach a satisfactory
conclusion until later in the Avatar
Saga for many fans this is infuriating
one person tweeted biggest issue feels
like a stepping stone for what's next
likewise a Reddit user was frustrated
that the valuable substance extracted by
humans from the brain to the Tolkien
that they brutally hunt down was
relevant for one scene and then
forgotten for the rest of the movie As
for the main characters it seems like
Kiri in particular won't get much payoff
until the sequels other fans wish the
film had explored why Kiri had a special
connection to the AWA and has seizures
underwater
heartbeat sound like mighty one redditor
concluded so much is left unresolved
debate for sequels I'm not invested in
yet not everyone felt this was a problem
as a redditor explained some very
Central and important characters are
basically only tagging along while some
other important characters get almost
all of the spotlight I'm sure these
characters will be given their moment in
future films so I will withhold final
judgment thankfully fans won't need to
wait another 13 years to see the payoff
Avatar 3 is projected to come out in
2024.
[Music]
foreign